would you believe Scientific American if
they told you that we had some way to
deflect a meteor I would go to yes but
when it came to anything that was
morally fashionable specifically race
gender trans issues ETC Not only would I
say no but I would say it's almost
invariably the truth is the opposite of
that thing I just don't know how we can
function as a society with all of these
institutions captured and large swaths
of the country not trusting them there's
this weird thing in today's age where
people think they have to agree with
literally everything everybody's like
all of someone's beliefs
before they can have a relationship or
be friends with them or something it's
very it's a very bizarre phenomenon
uh so you you and I have different
religious beliefs different metaphysical
beliefs which fall from that I'd like to
take a look at that and that that
doesn't affect our I mean like it's just
crazy to me to think that because people
have different metaphysical beliefs that
that would somehow intrude upon a
friendship of virtue I mean that's like
I don't even know why like even thinking
that itself is a kind of ideology I
think it's narcissism I mean if you
think that you're incapable of being
disagreed with and maintaining comedy
and committee uh then you're it's a sign
of a low rate intellect a midwit
intellect I think what distinguishes you
and I you know and and the way that our
colleagues and Friends of people we
respect and you've had on you know
millions of of just incredible
conversations and you yourself are one
of the best you know kind of uh public
intellectuals I always say you know if
you had a choice you know between Peter
begazian or almost any other Professor
you should have chosen him and I I
really when you left
um uh your campus previously uh Portland
State that
um that I said was a devastating day for
Portland State students and it was
something they wouldn't likely recover
from and because you are such you care
about lecturing and I hope that some of
the audience will want to talk about
education because Peter it's time we we
basically blow up a lot of Education the
higher education and from education at
the highest levels flow all the culture
wars and all the devastating nonsense we
call nourish kite and Yiddish just bull
crap nonsensical ideas it all flows
from Academia everything politics every
politician went to college you know
pretty much 100
all journalists do all the Twitter Audi
do
um they all go to college so therefore
if you want to kind of stop the
metastasization we must start at that
level just to set the stakes Peter as
you know I am not a theist in the in the
sense of my you know my Rabbi at that
same level I believe it's almost
presumptuous and as our mutual friend
Jordan Peterson says like who the hell
are you to say you believe in God like
oh God needs like Peter and Brian's you
know whatever but I am what I consider
to be a devout practicing you know card
carrying agnostic and for reasons I can
get into I believe that is the economic
ecumenical and also economical in the
Occam's razor sense parsimonious way for
a scientist like me who studies the Big
Bang origin of the universe Etc to
maintain okay there's just so much to
talk about I'm just I'm flooded with
thoughts right now so the other thing
that we need to talk about is when I was
in graduate school I I had a professor
literally yell at me when I asked him
why there couldn't be an infinite
regress he yelled at me like what why
well I've oh and I I had a um I've
talked about to our other mutual friend
Lawrence Cross I've talked to him about
this stuff uh at length so explain to me
why and I know you've said you you've
talked about the Multiverse and we have
a clip about that
um why can't there be an infinite
regress well certainly there can be you
know there's nothing
um everything that is not forbidden is
not only permissible but is mandatory uh
is the saying that we employ in quantum
mechanics so the question is is there
sufficient reason to believe that the
Multiverse exists and what becomes
uncomfortable for both Believers
theologically inclined Believers and
non-believers is that there is almost a
conflation there is there's an overlap
between the tenets and postulates of
those that don't believe in the
Multiverse and those that do and they're
diametrically opposed when it comes to
to theism so here's an example Steven C
Meyer is one of the leaders directors of
The Discovery Institute up in Seattle
right and he's a friend I've had him on
the show and he um and he maintains with
all his might and force that their
theory of what's called cosmological
inflation which we can explain is the
spark that ignited the big bang that we
now observe today
concomitant with that Lawrence Krauss
who's one of the staunchest atheists and
probably wouldn't talk to Stephen maybe
although he is the main character in
Steven's uh most recent book Return of
the god hypothesis they were supposed to
have a debate it didn't happen there's a
lot of hijinks involved you'll find out
about if you read the book which I I
blurbed uh as you as you may know but
the belief of Lawrence and and Stephen
are diametrically opposed when it comes
to the big banger or lack thereof so how
can these two different things be
reconciled well they can't unless the
underpinning of the theory is so
flexible so all-encompassing so squishy
that it admits you know these completely
diametric Downstream conclusions to be
drawn from the same Theory
that's a sign of an immature but not
necessarily incompetent or incomplete
theoretical framework and so the
question we have to ask is are these
part of the scientific Endeavor you know
the that great you know you you when you
come to visit me or I come to visit you
I'm going to bring you some some finger
puppets my audience knows that oh
excellent I am I'm used to fingering
Galileo I've got Carl Sagan here I've
got Einstein I've got them all I don't
have Peter I I love to finger you Peter
uh but uh but Galileo said our job as
scientist is to measure what's
measurable and make measurable what is
not yet so
and so you have to ask the question you
can speculate on these matters of wordy
philosophers as as Galileo used to
deride philosophers and sometimes
Lawrence Krauss does as well but at the
same token you should have sufficient
reason to do that so can you propose an
experiment that would reveal the
presence of the Multiverse uh or can you
only say we must wait or we must use
only only
uh indirect evidence as I wrote about in
skeptic magazine for Michael Shermer
I wrote about what if we're in a
situation where the belief in credulity
in a scientific field must be accepted
not on logical proof but on social proof
that's a scary situation can we agree
that
one cannot reason one's way to the
answer to the question of if there can
be an infinite regress can we agree that
you would need empirical evidence forget
about what the empirical evidence is but
can we agree that reason alone will not
answer the question
reason alone cannot answer that but
evidence may not also be forthcoming to
answer it as well okay so let's do very
slowly and construct this so if you and
I agree which we do that reason alone
cannot answer the question
then I think it follows from that that
we can also agree to the extent that
you're remotely knowledgeable about the
domain of philosophy many philosophers
have tried to do this they've tried to
kind of Reason their way to these things
but that you can't the way that you
answer that question is through science
it's not through really cool syllogisms
right right yes exactly and in fact I
want to just amplify that one more step
because I as a Jew find it very
distasteful when someone like Stephen C
Meyer or someone like William Lane Craig
all these guys have three names I I love
you know Prince and Madonna got buy with
just one I'm doing fine with two but um
they will start with the following chain
of syllogisms uh they will start by
saying anything that exists had a
beginning
column argument then they will say
um that which came you know from
something you know also you know cannot
come from nothing and that then they
will say things that were created had a
Creator and then finally they will say
Jesus is there for God correct and
that's that's difficult for me as a
practicing jew though not at the level
of you know my friend Ben Shapiro that
we can't necessarily get to an
extrapolation or proof of a Creator let
alone a personal Creator it's clear you
need such things but uh but that smacks
of the same type of infinite regress and
it's usually formed in the same way as
saying well if God is eternal then who
created God and then you get into these
infinite Turtles as well
right okay so the the Jesus part is not
part of the Quran but he adds that in as
a like you need a personal Creator and
if anybody's uh wondering about where
they can see the best summary of Craig's
views a c the best summary of Craig's
views not not Elite readily listen it's
his debate with Alex Rosenberg just
watch the Craig part I wouldn't watch
the Rosenberg part but he lays that out
in perfect syllogistic format but I
think that so many people have been
hoodwinked by thinking that they can
reason to
certain conclusions about the nature of
reality but reason is not the tool that
will get you there now let's bracket for
a second
what excuse me what evidence it would
take I'm just looking to formulate an
agreement with you that you cannot
reason to these things if that's true
then much of the domain of philosophy in
which philosophers attempt to do this
they're just spinning there I was going
to say uh uh expression but they're just
spinning their own wheels right
so you go ahead
no no I I'm I'm agreeing with you I
think yes there is a uh and I see people
saying in the chat oh no uh uh Craig
never mentions Jesus said no no but
that's not the point they're not there
to prove the existence of a God they're
they're there to prove the existence of
a personal God or else of what of what
use is such an entity and the god that
intervenes and answers prayers and
performs Miracles and causes Evolution
Etc so um so I would say you know we
talk about things like the Multiverse it
is possible for rational reasonable
people to extrapolate laws of physics in
you know kind of
incontrovertible laws of physics down to
the point where they no longer have
applicability let me give you an example
so yeah we talked about the or uh the
origin of the universe is originating
from a big bang all of our lines of
evidence point to the fact that the
Universe had has been evolving has been
getting cooler has been getting more
tenuous less dense and um and hori in
its old age now that implies based on
you know kind of modus tollens that you
just run the clock backwards and it was
more dense hotter more pressure more
more dense Etc then you come to a point
where you get to a point where
mathematically You can predict a
singularity now what's interesting about
singularities you know where you divide
a finite quantity into an infinitesimal
or zero volume say matter uh finite
amount of matter compressed to infinite
density is a singularity in density uh
those would also be correlated
singularities in pressure and
temperature the math works the math
maths out just fine but the physics is
completely unpredictable we can't say
what happens once you get below the
plank length which is something like 10
to the minus 40th meters when you get to
such you know infinitesimal length
scales the human brain Peter is the only
you know organ we think exists in the
universe that can contemplate what
Infinity means when I put Infinity into
my computer I get out not a number you
know I take 1 divided by zero you get
not a number n a n you um you don't get
a sensible value the computer can't Pro
but we could process it just fine human
brains can do that uniquely so so
conversely I'll just I'll just finish
this last touch point
the the extrapolation mathematically can
be used by both William Lane Craig
Lawrence Krauss and Steven C Meyer to
extrapolate to a point where
should properly be said
that our physics has broken down our
ability to describe the physical
Universe with mathematical laws is
incomplete I read and blurbed actually
someone who is a mentor to me was I
didn't really understand because I'm not
a particle physicist Victor stenger
wrote God in the Multiverse and I don't
know if you read that but I did I
remember you told me about it yeah yeah
and and so he claims that there's
sufficient evidence to Warrant belief
now there's a clip of you to warm belief
in a Multiverse evidence being the key
word in that sentence there's a clip of
you talking about the Multiverse that
Reid will pull up in a second but the
the here's how it goes from the point of
view of many contemporary Christian
apologists uh led by William Lynn Craig
he'll say and he'll invoke velenken
he'll talk about the big bang and he'll
say the reason that people
believe
or claim to believe in the Multiverse is
because they they want to deny the god
hypothesis they want to deny the first
cause this kind of Aristotelian boom
and
so you have to pause it something so
it's more of an it's more of um
a kind of metaphysics that's posited to
avoid an inevitable epistemological
conclusion and that is that God exists
Victor Stein writes and again this is
the Victor science obviously not a
particle physicist but he wrote about
something that I find to be a there's
only necessity in logic there's no
necessity in the world and so when I see
people try to think about a unified
field theories and come up with string
theories I'm I'm just again I'm not a
physicist but I'm wondering like why
would people even think that there's
necessity there like why would people
even think that I understand why someone
would think it's possible but why would
someone think it's necessary
does that make sense well just explain
one more time what that what is
necessary that that there even would be
a unified field Theory like why would
anybody think that
yeah I don't understand
yes I I agree so um so let's take a step
back what is a unified uh field Theory
um and it Stakes back to uh to the
Discovery by none other than another
three-name individual James Clerk
Maxwell and I don't have a doll of him
but what he did is he studied and
investigated the properties of
electricity and magnetism which were
thought to be two disparate things as
different from one another as a magnetic
field is from a gravitational field as
the force that drops this thing down
just there losing my media right and by
the way Peter because I love college
students and I know you do too and I
love graduate students postdocs I even
loved some professors Peter okay
um I give away these meteorites to
anybody with an edu email address if you
go to Brian keating.com edu and you have
an edu email address you sign up for it
I will send you guaranteed a chunk of
4.3 billion year old meteorite material
I'm going to send one to you Peter once
you become a professor again no no I I
really want you down here at UCSD so but
what what uh what Mr uh what Mr Maxwell
James Clark Maxwell did is he reconciled
the fact that the electric field imposed
on such an object could be understood in
another sense by an observer saying a
moving magnetic moving uh reference
frame as an electric field and vice
versa you could convert electric fields
to magnetic fields and it was known that
they had something to do with each other
but he unified them this set off a path
of unification that continues to this
day with people like my great friend
Eric Weinstein and others who are still
trying to unify gravity with these three
other forces the three other forces are
the strong nuclear force which is
responsible for Atomic uh which is
responsible for Atomic uh fission and
fusion The Binding Together of the
nuclei in the movie Oppenheimer I did a
video about that the physics of
Oppenheimer semi-viral movie on my
channel
and that um that unified that with with
uh with or the belief is that the weak
Force which is responsible for what's
called radioactive decay
that that force is Unified we know now
thanks to the work of abdisalam and
Stephen Weinberg that uh and Shelly
glasshow that they're unified with
electricity and magnetism in other words
the same types of fields and forces are
in sort of this family tree
that you NE that relate electricity you
know electric carrying wires and
resistors to magnets refrigerator
magnets and maybe superconducting uh the
devices
those are related genetically to the
weak nuclear force which couldn't be
more shocking so then the logic took
over well if those are unified okay
maybe maybe the nuclear force that binds
proton to proton remember a proton
shouldn't be able to bind to a proton
feeder they're both positively charged
they should repel each other well guess
what they don't except if you put a
neutron in there so it's very unusual to
get two things to stick together that
are repulsive that hate each other yeah
that are like the faculty and the
bureaucratic staff at the University you
have to bring together a third a
different element a different type of
constituent like a student and that
moderates the force of repulsion and
causes a force of attraction
that's called the uh Grand unified
theory or g-u-t and then finally If
gravity could be made to be unified with
those other three forces we'd have a
theory of everything but we don't
currently even have and I say even I'm
not a theorist but we don't have and I
don't want to minimize it's very hard to
do yeah a grand unified theory right and
yet we're looking for theories of
everything so I always joke Peter it's
hilarious dad jokes that I'm known for
we're putting the toe before the gut
so you have to be careful yeah so the
fact that I followed 99 of that tells me
that you're incredibly incredibly good
explainer
so okay so let me repeat back to you
the answer to my question
so you're saying that there's not
necessarily a necessity that there's a
unified field Theory but because other
elements have been unified at different
scales we can extrapolate and make
reasonable inferences from that that
it's very likely I don't want to give a
probability Vector to that but it's at
least likely
what degree of possibility is it
possible to the extent that it's likely
I mean I don't want to get too much far
down the weeds because but there are
people that claim the success of the
unification of electricity and magnetism
together and then electricity magnetism
in the weak Force provides ample
um hope and reason to search for a grand
unified theory I think the notion that
there's a there's a a Theory of
Everything which unifies all four forces
together is is taken for granted as I
said people pursue that because here's
the deal Peter what happens is people
think in physics you know they have a
Target on this guy's back this is Albert
Einstein if you're listening and they
wanna they wanna you know shoot that
Target they I want to say that where he
failed I will succeed so I get letters I
get emails Professor Keating Einstein
was wrong I can show you how the unified
is I'm not good in math
um so if you help me prove it then we
can split the Nobel Prize together and
I'll only take you know two-thirds okay
so we get a lot of that uh because it's
such it's the Paragon Paragon of of the
human brain as as Einstein where he
failed if I can succeed there therefore
I get all his direct Dungeons and
Dragons hit points his life force and I
am superseding him now you're speaking
my language Brian you're speaking my
language keep going you roll the isaka
edron akasahedral dice and then you're
in but no so uh but that's not to say
there aren't reasons to pursue it as I
mentioned Eric Weinstein is very much
convinced that he has a contender Theory
of Everything that explains a lot but it
has to admit other currently
unobservable phenomena such as the fact
that in his theory there are multiple
time Dimensions so we we've talked about
space time in physics for years that's
the unification of space up down left
and right and forwards and backwards
namely the three dimensions of degrees
of freedom in space with the time
Dimension I want to meet you for this
podcast I had to be in a certain place
at a certain time that's four dimensions
needed to be adhered to right
um what Eric and others have thought
about is well what if you extrapolated
that to even higher dimensions in Eric's
case something like 10 dimensions and
what if time is not a mono you know
monorail that goes in One Direction it
could potentially go backwards and
forwards but there's an orthogonal time
direction that we have no real
connection to and Hawking and others did
postulate that as well um so he's in
good company now there are other
theorists like Sheldon glacio who won
the Nobel Prize for the unification
electricity he also tried a similar vein
there's something called Batista Ed
Whitton has tried to do this with string
theory did Ed witton is behind
everything that like virtually
everything that's just insanely out
there but yeah go ahead yeah yeah I have
a lot of trouble with him I he is uh one
of the foremost selfies
truly on his own level like Ed Whitton
is he's just a look at his yeah if you
look at his Twitter feed do you think
that he's like a nom Chomsky or somebody
but oh really in terms of this feeling
about Israel it's every only nothing
about physics or math only about about
Israel's atrocities you know carried out
against the Hamas and and Palestinians
it's amazing with all these the stuff
that he does he thinks about anything
else but okay so yeah we'll get back to
it yeah yeah go ahead go ahead what I
would like to see is more experimental
um backing not not I think we have an
overabundance I always make the analogy
like theoretical ideas are like software
it's it's it's relatively you know cheap
because one person can make great
software but takes a lot of people to
build the computer that the software is
programmed I'm not criticizing I think
you know theorists at all I mean some of
my best friends are theorists but the
bottom line is we we need to have
empirical empiricism to work 100 100
okay so let me ask you a question so
you know I'm very friendly with with
Eric I like Eric we just hung out in
London
um with Winston uh and and um
I listened to Eric talk about this I
have dude I have no idea what he's
talking about like like I could not even
like it's just so like
nothing zero it just does not and I was
talking to Shermer about this so what
here's what I understand so let's say
that that Eric is correct and I haven't
asked him this so it's perhaps it should
be more I should have asked him before I
asked you but it's not a dig on Eric I'm
just a genuinely curious let's say that
his models are correct why doesn't he
publish that in peer-reviewed journals
oh okay so now we're getting into like
some really controversial stuff so Eric
Eric is uh perhaps the most interesting
and and Mercurial and and uh
delightfully challenging person that
I've ever met um I was listening to an
interview with Sam Harris who I hope we
can get to Sam uh talk about him in in a
bit but um but no but I was just
thinking like I get to talk to Eric and
Eric just to my mind just just
completely obliterates in the public
intellectual space Sam uh on every level
and and he's so much more
um kind of just articulate but his his
ability to articulate and his humility
which I don't believe Sam has at the
same level I forgot do you know Sam well
or no very well and I and I don't wanna
you know I'd love to talk to Sama he's
never been on like a a very high level
scientifically oriented podcast I mean
he he's been on with many people and
maybe he's not he's not a he's not a
physicist though no but I've had on you
know I talked to the economists who
Nobel prize-winning economy you know I
don't need to people come on the show Oh
I thought you I thought you meant to
talk to to talk about Eric's Theory no
no not at all no no I'm just saying like
he was talking about other things so
when I what I mean to say about Eric is
that he
there's no um Eric's mind works in
multiple dimensions in ways that normal
people can't really contemplate so for
example when we talk about peer review
he is already like five steps down the
road so if you ask Eric he will say peer
review is not should not be part of
Science in fact his pinned tweet on
Twitter for a long time was we should
talk about this graph and it was you
know the Google engram of how many times
peer review has been mentioned in a
given oh the past 100 years and it was
Zero until the 40s and then it spiked up
okay so that's one thing peer review is
not that traditional it's not that
irrelevant number two
um who started peer review as a kind of
cynical non of good science or
shibboleth well it turns out there was
this publishing company called pergamon
I believe and they were affiliated with
a couple of other people and then all
these academic universities had to buy
subscriptions to journals and then the
journals hire you know reviewers but
they don't pay them anything and all
that's true and then one of the leaders
and the funders of this of this peer
review kind of industry was Jeffrey
Epstein's father okay so
um so for that reason he's like
unwilling um there are other you know
yes like you know and and he should
speak for himself if he's interested in
coming on but but the bottom line is he
does not hold by peer review so this is
not something about in fact when he
published quote unquote his
um his most recent
disputations about what he calls
geometric Unity it was first shown on
Joe Rogan's podcast immediately shown on
mine you know live from Austin Texas
from his hotel room and we went into the
details of it that you know Joe is not
going to go into on the physicist level
um but he copyrighted it as a work of
entertainment so that it couldn't be uh
it could not be a plagiarized by uh
forces such as those that Eric has
claimed proof and demonstrate a
demonstratable proof has copied his
ideas in the past and some of his claims
are are very meritorious in my in my
opinion not all of them necessarily I'm
not saying he's lying but I'm just
saying I haven't investigated them but
at least one or two I've personally
investigated and found him to be to be
correct so peer review is a good for
science so I actually disagree with Eric
I take the churchillian perspective that
peer review is the worst form of
advocacy and argumentation about science
and um uh discourse except for all the
others
in that we have this tradition and it's
not perfect I just got back from the uh
London myself and when I was in London I
had the great honor of speaking at the
Royal Institution this is when I saw
that excellent yeah congratulations yeah
it was a wonderful thing and it was
where Michael Faraday who first invented
the concept we talked about Fields he
came up with the idea of the field what
is the magnetic field was electric field
and I got to use his exact experiments
with wax paper with iron filings and
magnets and it was it was a treat of a
lifetime my wife and two of my kids
there it was such a wonderful treat
Peter I can't explain it and it's part
of What's called the discourse which is
never supposed to end in other words I
was locked in a room and they didn't
announce who I was they didn't introduce
me I just come bursting out through this
door in the Faraday cage yeah this
continuing lecture series That Never
Ends uh dating back to apocryphaly when
some speaker failed to show up and
Michael Faraday had to give the lecture
anyway getting back to this so when I
did that I was reminded that this is the
way that people would announce things
that they would do Discovery they
wouldn't do it in a journal a journal
didn't exist in 1826 instead they would
come there and say I believe that this
chunk of meteorite which your dot edu
email address will get you is 4 billion
years old and they would do an
experiment with a geiger tube or you
know some sort of uh uh you know uh
proof or J.J Thompson demonstrated the
existence of the electron and like live
in person it was incredible and I was
using some of their same equipment so
well that's an alternative right so you
can think of other Alternatives uh you
could think of subject or domain
expertise I will say though that uh it
is very difficult to construe a way of
of adversarial but it should be not um
not ad hominem
critiquing of scientific presentations
and Eric's is of the opposite he thinks
it's bad for science I think it's
neutral to slightly good uh and
especially compared to all the others
could Eric demonstrate his model live no
he's not it's not an experimental model
so the access to this if you've seen
Oppenheimer plan to first check out my
video on my Channel about the physics of
webinar
um for because they left out all the
physics all the fun nerdy stuff that I
went to go see it for and I was like I
got as much physics out of Barbie as
that but
um when you talk about the physics of
the nuclear now we're talking about the
physics of space-time so to go from the
electronic scale the scale of chemistry
the scale of refrigerator magnets the
energy scale associated with an electric
shock it may hurt you now you go to the
nuclear scale and you have Hiroshima
okay okay now what Eric wants to do is
get to the sub nuclear scale the
space-time scale can you imagine the
conflagration that it would take to
demonstrate such a such a theory so no
um no Peter we couldn't demonstrate it
is it at least in theory capable of
being demonstrated that it's
that it that it aligns with reality I
don't want to say that it's true yeah so
so he could you could
do these like live like a like a magic
show anymore and there is there was an
element of Showmanship and and there was
stuff that I did you know that's just
yeah it is like a live magic trick right
but um but no I mean what Eric should do
is is indeed publish it and and indeed
look for criticism of it respond to that
criticism the problem with Eric's
theories ideas is because he's such an
influential uh public intellectual
because he's probably one of the
brightest living human beings because of
that he's attracted a huge Cadre of
people that would love to see him fail
because 100 I see that a hundred percent
yeah they have uh he has a massive
massive Target on his back and and just
to buttress what you're saying you know
every time I've I've hung out with Eric
I found him to be
um I I found
everything you've said about him to be
absolutely true he's very affable as
well I really I really like him as a
person
um but with all that being said I'm just
I have literally nothing to to say to
him about physics I like I couldn't I
know I just don't know enough to I
wouldn't even begin to know
a root you know saying so like having
that conversation with me would be
totally pointless no in fact so I've
I've done that I've had him down I've
invited him down to UCSD a couple years
ago he was sort of a visitor you know
permanent visitor and now he's you know
on occasion we'll visit
um me from LA but um but we actually had
a quote unquote debate with with another
colleague of mine Daniel Green who's a
brilliant young you know 30s 40s guys
good looking brilliant you know great
father great great he's just a guy you
hate right uh but he no I love him but
uh and they talked and debated live and
it was and there was great comity they
did not fight with each other there's no
ad hominem attacks and I could tell Eric
left that conversation feeling energized
and Alive knowing that there were not
only you know physics kind of wannabes
out there but actual you know highly
cited practicing theoretical
cosmologists that were taking him
seriously that could debate with him
that he could hold his own with and and
and at some levels go deeper and so but
when you have people on the internet you
know who want to see him fall like
dedicate podcasts that that go on venues
and then attack his paper using a
pseudonymous names
um so that you can't verify is this
person uh the same person that um said
something that was uh misgendering
somebody
um and or or is that person somebody
who's who's you know causing people to
come to people's houses uh we don't know
because that person's name so at that
level now there is a very public critic
movement has made his name known
um uh online and is frequently critic
and he he also loves to try to engage me
in it and and actually that is I think
he's a brilliant you know he won't use
his name I don't care uh but but you
know he's had like four or five podcasts
Peter on his podcast about me my book
Eric trying to get you know other
scientists to comment on the quality of
my science or or some of the things and
why is it bad that I don't have him on
my podcast
um look I find it flattering at some
level because every time he mentions me
I get this great boost because he's such
a brilliant young guy this this guy
who's criticizing Eric however
um I don't find that he's acting in good
faith I feel like he wants him from you
know and I've seen attacks and so anyway
um I'm happy to talk to anybody they
have to be doing it in good faith and
they have to be doing it from a point of
view of trying to have Clarity not just
taking somebody down and like uh
standing over them and revealing them to
be the grifter and and everything else
yeah
that's what happens when you move at
high levels in the public space is that
the number of lunatics Who come out of
the woodwork in bad faith accusations I
mean if you think it's bad I don't think
this guy's a lunatic at all I think no
no I'm not I'm not talking about him
specifically I'm just talking about the
the number of insane people who come out
who literally has a huge Target and if
you think it's bad for Eric it's a
thousand it's it's so much worse for his
brother I mean they they come after
Brett like
crazy crazy like and just the sheer
vituperation the sheer nastiness the
sheer
and that's part of the problem is you
don't really know if it's 50 people or 5
000 people like 50 people with a hundred
kind of sock puppet accounts so there is
a kind of and I do think there's
something about the anonymity and those
that bothers me in a way that when you
move into public school in a high at a
high level and you have these huge
Targets on your back like you have like
Eric has and and uh yeah I I
I mean something I never say in person
right if somebody say to me about my
friend Eric if they were to say he's a
grifter and a fraud yeah you're gonna
find something out about me and you know
the kind of the kind of you know
physicality that I'm I'm willing to to
maintain uh if you're if you're if
you're actively threatening me or my
friends okay now on the internet that
doesn't happen right I mean people
there's no repercussion you're not gonna
get punched in the face somebody once
said that and actually one of the things
that Sam Harris did say that I did agree
with is like you know most of the worst
weekends of my life you know in the last
10 years were because of something I
said on Twitter that's that's what he
said so why are we inviting this thing
in the in the you know it's just because
I'm a you know I'm a narcissist and I
want public affirmation yeah okay so you
just you just okay so that right there I
have to pause and say it's like okay so
when you do this thing that we do when
people come after you online you just
can't I mean you just have to be
non-fased by you just cannot let these
people get to you because the moment
that that happens you know Helen pluck
Rose they've really got a number on her
oh yeah they've called her horrible
things mostly about her weight and she
you know she had a a problem like a cyst
was on her brain and she used to be an
athlete and I mean what people have said
about her and done to her is horrific
instead of engaging her ideas but you
just can't let these people get to you
that's that's the thing you just no I
agree and and I and that's why I was
wondering
why about the whole peer review with
Eric thing uh why that just doesn't go
through peer review and I thought you
were going to say that the journals were
institutionally captured but that
reminds me if if I can just
you know use the word orthogonal I love
that word if I can just go go to go to
some something you know the whole Joe
Rogan uh put up ten to ten thousand
dollars or a hundred a hundred a hundred
thousand dollars to debate uh yeah Peter
Hotes yep with um RFK
yeah I'm interested in your take on that
but because it's it it parallels this
conversation yeah but I'd like to give
you mine and and maybe you tell me if my
thinking my reasoning is an error so
Peter went on his podcast before so he
already moved in the public space he has
a Twitter account so he's not a
scientist who has avoided the public
space that's right so I think it's
incumbent upon him because he's in the
public space to accept that that
challenge yeah okay I'd love to talk to
Joe Rogan about this and God willing
someday I'll get that chance Peter um
but um but I thought you know there is
this constant refrain from Peter Hotes
um first of all there are all these
baseless really slimy kind of um
accusations that Joe was doing that as
uh as kind of like an anti-semitic Trope
I don't even know Peter Hotes is Jewish
that's insane I'm not even sure he is
but I was like crazy talk yeah yeah it
was a reporter from the Atlantic or the
New York Times it was um from David
Froome I think oh yeah so uh so I wrote
David fernback I was just like yeah it's
uh it's it's already bad because this
anti-semite already had Peter hotez on
this pot it was clear like he didn't
even know that he had been like fruit
was saying oh don't give him a platform
okay it's a great it's a great uh line
except for when you actually do a second
of research as a reporter and see that
he had already been on the podcast and
treated wonderfully
um second of all when he says oh we
don't debate that's nonsense we do
debate we don't allow a debate on
Twitter or Joe Rogan Experience to count
and replace
substitutionally peer review
um on the other hand we also you know um
it wasn't just that he said well I won't
like scientists don't debate so you're
saying if you had on you know if I could
talk to
um you know or topal which who I have
talked to and you know you wouldn't
debate him you know he he felt we
shouldn't give the vaccine out before
the 2020 election because that would
redound to Trump's benefit
so I claim if he believed that Peter and
correct me if I'm wrong logically
speaking but if Eric believed that was
true Eric told Paul
and it turned out that the vaccine
indeed did save lives then by
withholding the vaccine from the public
and using his influence to do so then
lives were lost I don't think you can
say both things the viruses vaccine is
100 effective or was effective save
lives and if it was administered earlier
it wouldn't have said so anyway would
Peter Hotes not debate one of the
foremost you know kind of uh researchers
and public figures namely Eric talpal of
course he would so it's it's a nonsense
to say that they don't participate in
public today he didn't want to and and
he knows that RFK is more skilled but I
actually don't think RFK is the best
Exemplar
um of this point but that should redown
to Peter hotes's benefit because yes he
may be more skilled oratorially but
scientifically shouldn't Peter Hotes
have so much better scientific apparatus
and Joe mediate and moderate that so I
thought it was a cop-out okay so so let
me ask you at least one perhaps two
questions I want to see if we can find
agreement or if we disagree on this
would you agree that if somebody was a
scientist with no Twitter account never
been on a podcast but they worked in
this field and then somebody challenged
them to a debate there's just no a
public debate in a public forum maybe
they should consider it but it is an
unreasonable expectation for for other
people to
want them to do that would you agree
that if someone already does not move in
the public space that there's no
compulsion to do so I actually think
that scientists who do receive Public
Funding are uh have a moral obligation
to engage with the public at some level
it doesn't mean like every time they're
challenged by a flat earther I have to
go and debate them and put on my
debating clogs and do that no it means
that I receive Public Funding and I have
a responsibility as a mensch and and as
a as an individual who is you know
responsible for the fiduciary obligation
that we have a scientist to spend other
people's money namely U.S taxpayers to
do it why wisely and to do it
judiciously that's an obligation that I
feel I have that's the reason I started
my YouTube channel uh and so forth if
you don't want to do that you know
that's fine I often get the saying I
actually was had a conversation with
this guy Dave Farina who actually calls
people like Steven C Meyer and others uh
charlatans grifters and just hateful
individuals I mean he is really
vehemently antagonistic towards The
Discovery Institute towards this guy
James tour and other people but he even
said well no it's not in their skill set
I want them staying in the lab where
they'll do the most good I said imagine
you work for a t and and you're doing
you know um marketing for them and your
boss comes by
and your boss says hey Brian what are
you up to and he's ah look I'm doing
very complicated things things that you
may not understand you know uh and and
so forth Mr because you would say pack
up your stuff by the end of the day and
the security card will take away your
badge because you have no right to tell
me how you are too intelligent erudite
and wise and you should have a blank
check on how you spend your money with
no accountability and no fiduciary duty
and yet that's what we as scientists are
doing
so okay uh there is an obligation
there's an obligation to meet me on the
Potter's field at six in the morning
with pistols at dawn that's not that's
not it seems to me that because RFK now
is he a viable presidential candidate I
don't know but you know he has a large x
following on Twitter whatever you want
he has a very large public platform a
lot of people listen to him it would
seem to me
given that there's an additional
responsibility on someone who who is a
scientist because of the political
nature
of both the claim and the person with
whom you'd be having that discussion is
that is my reasoning uh I mean what do
you think what do you think about that I
mean do they have an obligation or you
know to be part obligation might be too
strong but because this is a
presidential candidate with an not an
unreasonable likelihood of success but
there's there just seems to be an
additional gravitas or Duty or
responsibility because it's RFK well let
me flip it around you so if I've learned
nothing else by the way when you were on
my podcast
um it was uh it was it was such a
delight and I really want you back on I
want to do it in person in my in my new
impossible Studios but um but Peter the
comments were like because I was asking
you things they were debating religion
and talking about like experts and
follow the science and what does that
mean and then in the comments it was
there were all these comments like
Peter's using all the tools of how to
have impossible conversations with Brian
kidding in real time and Keating is too
oblivious to understand he is getting
one pulled anyway uh so I'm going to
pull one over on you okay so let's see
let me take the opposite so let me say
this is it reasonable that Peter Hotes
shouldn't engage with somebody who has
said things conflating vaccines with
autism and uh and uh conflating the
fiduciary venality of the pharmaceutical
industry with um with the profit motive
and with their policy directives and so
for engaging with these people would it
not be like you know Ben Shapiro runs
for uh runs for office and he's asked to
debate a holocaust denier yeah now I
hate the word vaccine denier I hate
climate denier I just had on a wonderful
uh professor at NYU Stephen coonan who's
been called a climate change denier I've
been called a Multiverse denier
the currency
you know so yeah that's awesome
Multiverse denier
but the bottom line is you know to what
obligation do you have now on a platform
like Rogan I thought it was disingenuous
which doesn't mean that he wasn't right
to maybe not debate with um with with
RFK himself I think RFK is is is a very
skilled auditor he's been in the public
Sphere for a long time he's got
bonafide's
um so I think hotels was was you know I
think he was scared to do it I think
he's oh for sure not to do it and maybe
there's some venue but he wasn't
actively proposing it so let's say Eric
doesn't want to do peer review or Sam
Harris doesn't want to be on Twitter
um you know are there ways that they can
have their own Echo chamber punctuated
or punctured rather and I I found this
listening to Sam you know he was he's so
kind of just he's such a brilliant mind
that I think in his mind he's convinced
himself that there are no flaws in in
his logic and so it is like debating you
know is two plus two equal five and so
it's not worth his time on the other
hand there's ample evidence to show that
a lot of the things that he would claim
were preferable to Trump you know never
happened I listened to a podcast that he
did
um with this guy Scott Galloway who's a
professor so-called professor at NYU
he's not like I don't know teaching
staff and he is probably Prophet he's on
with Kara Swisher they have a podcast if
you know her
um I think she called for Ben Shapiro to
be de-platformed once uh on on YouTube
because her son likes to watch uh Ben
Shapiro anyway
um so this conversation was was from
2020 and it was all about the dangers of
re-electing trump and how it's an
existential threat and so Scott and Sam
Harris were debating how it could lead
to like a new invasion of Ukraine
it could lead to tensions with Iran you
know and and it could lead to you know
Chinese interference and um and and I'm
like do you guys like ever do an audit
on yourselves like Scott Galloway or Sam
have you ever look back and say look
when we predicted this we were wrong
like I made a mistake and and that's
that's fine to do that I actually just
and it's totally different context I
just did an interview with a renowned
theoretical physicist you know your
paper the the
um the uh hermeneutic penis the
conceptual penis is a social contract
one of the highest uh in in gender
studies it's one of the most cited
papers in all of gender studies did you
know what that is do you know what your
H index is or what that papers uh no but
the funny thing is it's still cited uh
as a real paper even though it's not
available online anymore it's still it's
still cited that testifies to the
rigidity to the durability of the
conceptual penis thank you thank you
there's something called an H index and
we're going to nerd out as professors
that is the number of papers that you
have that have at least H citations so
it's a metric a parametric measurement
of your of your throughput and
creativity and output as a as a
professor as a scientist okay so someone
could have one paper that has a million
citations and never write another paper
and that's you know that's that's
interesting that's useful that that
might be a one-hit wonder or someone
could have ten thousand papers that have
each been cited a hundred times and that
might be even more uh indicative of that
professor's impact on the field so it's
an impact factor assessment the person
who invented that statistic is Jorge
Hirsch I think the H stands for Hersh
he's my colleague at UCSD he was a very
great skeptic of the superconductor
that's recently been announced
operational at room temperature and I
know you want to get into type two types
I actually I actually do phase one
superconductors and also talk about
levitation and meissner effect and we
will do that and quantum computers I
just had them on my podcast a few hours
ago and he's changed his mind and he's
big enough to do he's one of the biggest
naysayers now he's so Sam Harris can't
come out and say look I was wrong I
don't think we would have had a fascist
State I think we maybe have descended
more into kind of fascist or suppression
of free speech under Biden potentially
and maybe Biden is more as corrupt as I
thought when I said on trigonometry that
you know he could have you know dead
babies in his on his laptop
anyway this is all to say that um that
there's that there's no obligation to
debate but I think you shouldn't shy
away from it and if you do find another
venue say I don't want to debate let's
have a debate on uh on you know
peterbegazian.com let's have a written
debate or let's do it live or you know
whatever but but to say completely it's
not he's beneath me I think that's
insulting to the scientific process yeah
I mean I can speculate the psychological
reasons and the social reasons why he
didn't want to debate but you've
mentioned Sam Harris a number of times
so I think we should talk to that but
beforehand hey Reed pull up the uh we
have a super chat question about the
trustworthiness of science
uh whether it and thank Maverick
Christian we appreciate this uh you know
I have a non-profit all the everything
goes to the nonprofit to allow us to do
this uh when I get 20 of it right you
get 20 of her just just 20. uh whether
to trust the majority scientific opinion
in practice boils down to who do you
trust when you lack the relevant
expertise to judge BS which can go awry
for example creationism uh we should
talk about that because Dawkins does not
debate creationists because he says it
gives them the quote oxygen of
legitimacy uh and how do you navigate
that so that's actually a great question
for you yeah so when I think about you
know who who do you trust you have to
trust is earned just like in life and
ever all of us have a moral and ethical
bank account and I think you can draw
upon it you can be right I I may I may
have declared that we discovered the
imprimatur of the singularity that began
our universe but I also was part of a
team that retracted it and worked
overturn it and that's the story of my
first book losing the Nobel Prize
spoiler alert no I lost it great book by
the way I loved it loved it thank you
thank you very much uh and uh and yet
and yet you should have the intellectual
capacity to say that does not invalidate
you there's a Trope that you know a
scientist only has to be right once in
their life to be in a successful career
and only wrong ones to have no career um
that's not really true the problem is
that the Public Communication of science
is a unidirectional ratchet that only
allows the amplification of of
sensationalism and never the actual
sausage retraction being made and I'll
give you an example so when there are
claims like the one involving my
experiment bicep or say one involving a
room temperature superconductor from
years ago or cold fusion
that comes out on the front page of
every newspaper around the world correct
and it happened to us and it comes out
and it leads above the fold and then and
then if there is a retraction that will
occur on page B17 of the Saturday
edition which is the least read of all
seven editions of a newspaper if at all
it'll never be on TV and so I've called
for rather controversial sort of a PR
budget ratio where you have in reserve
you have to publicize your results
you're getting taxpayer money all of us
scientists are funded by the taxpayers
even though people like me who receive a
lot of private funding in the
preponderance of my funding is from a
private Foundation nevertheless I was I
teach at a public university I've uh you
know used been educated in the public
school system my whole life
um etc etc so for these reasons we have
an obligation however we should keep
some of our budget in reserve I've
called 10 20 call in reserve to
publicize at the same level of of
attention that the initial announcement
got and you must keep working with the
media and I call this the academic media
hype cycle because something will be
found like a claim that the universe is
26 billion years old and that'll be one
person working in Ottawa Canada is a
legitimate professor
and he would claim this and then it will
get picked up by a couple of physics you
know news sources that have the word
physics in it or scientists in it and
then Joe Rogan will will post it and
then Elon Musk will retweet and ask
questions about Dark Matter subsequent
too and this really happened two weeks
ago if I ever do talk to Joe I'll gonna
bring this up because the the fact is
having this one researcher kind of
present a single finding that's not
vetted or really
um uh consistent or coherent with the
majority of the field and it turns out
this researcher also had felt pressure
from his home institution to make a
press release which then gets picked up
by a local newspaper which then goes to
a national website which then goes to
Joe Rogan so this got tens of millions
of views now if it turns out as I think
it is incorrect it doesn't mean he's a
fool or he's an idiot it just means that
his logical reasoning process was meant
to fit an outcome rather than you know
blindly apply to data as a random
control you know trial so to would uh
hopefully allow us to do so if that
occurs if Joe Rogan gonna put another
tweet I was wrong
um you know this isn't yeah he might I'm
the blaming Joe I'm not really yeah I'm
not really mad at him but I'm just
saying when the the pan city as as Mark
Twain said or somebody said uh maybe it
was Sam Clemens not Mark Twain that you
know a lie goes all the way around the
world before the truth puts on its pants
um I'm not saying these are liars not
saying these are fraudsters but the lack
of resources Financial Resources
dedicated to this and I get this from a
talmudic perspective it'll be
interesting so in the talmud if you say
Peter says I witness Brian Keating
um trying to murder somebody okay or
actually murdering somebody okay and you
didn't actually see that and if but if
you did see it I would be convicted of
that and I would be put to death if you
say that Peter and it's proven that you
lied then you get the punishment you get
executed
okay in other words the thing that you
would have brought upon me gets brought
upon you so I'm using this in the
talmudic sense to apply to Scientific
publication retractions the amount of
attention you had put into this to
either Garner attention research funding
Nobel prizes um Fame attention
that you must maintain in reserve and
insurance policy and that insurance
policy is to retract at the same level
that you promoted okay so I followed and
I agree bracketing the death thing I I
followed and I agree with what you say
and what's making it made me think about
something that I've been thinking about
for a while it's just this idea of the
death of expertise it's how we've come
to a legitimation crisis or a legitimacy
crisis our institutions we don't we're
inherently distrustful of expertise and
you've spoken with Jay about acharya
about this and uh others have spoken
about Brett has spoken about this and do
you think the following scientific
institutions are trustworthy so I was
wondering if you could comment on like
Scientific American has is completely
lost I mean I'm just amazed at what's
happened to that these venerable Legacy
institutions the journal Nature Center
for Disease Control
World health organizations and then I
have a good friend of mine who who works
for the CDC and I'll tell her I'll tell
you what what she said
um what do you think about like the the
fact that are these trustworthy and how
do you relate that to expertise and if
you can to the legitimate this is a
complex question I'm trying to not ask
compound questions but no they're better
than me because that's okay
crisis yeah so so what do you what do
you think about like the trustworthiness
of our institutions and the fact that
the public just my buddy said to me the
other day if there's a if there actually
is a pandemic that's literally like
black plague level No One's Gonna
believe it like yeah literally no by the
way don't say if say when
and I talked to Jay about this uh my
podcast as well and no one's gonna
believe it
you know this could be uh kind of a
preview and a a terrifying one at that
of the real pandemic God forbid Peter
imagine if or Zeus or whatever you
believe nothing nature favorite uh that
there is a pandemic and it kills not the
89 year old you know people in nursing
homes which is tragic but uh eight nine
year olds okay yeah um so so just
imagine what what would it would Branch
Society I don't think we would have the
same kind of planetary scale reaction
that we did and so did we dodge a bullet
well but but maybe we didn't because the
next one could attack God forbid as I
say um and then we're we got all these
people like my kids had to go in for
their Tdap vaccine I was like well you
know how many people really get tetanus
in the U.S you know I was like looking
at I remember talking to Brett Weinstein
on my podcast and and he was like I got
the rabies shot and I was like oh well
big big freaking deal yeah I got
attention he's like no like very few
human beings get the rabies shot like
it's so rare that you get rabies and um
you know he had to go to like collect
fruit bats or something you know
whatever
um so the bottom line is like you start
thinking about this well like are like
the HPV vaccine yeah well how many like
am I saying to my wife like we are
expecting our kids to have sex out of
wedlock and when they do they will be
sleeping with a partner who has
um who has you know these polyps or has
this um uh hepatitis or whatever it is
and uh and then they'll get canceled
like what are we saying here like just
to pause that for a second so uh HPV is
linked to cervical cancer in women and
so there's some really interesting uh uh
literature that I read a while ago and
about public health campaigns Etc so the
HPV vaccine is if they have sex that
they're
um you know you you want to ward off
that like that possibility of cancer so
I think yeah
the most probable age that they would
get cancers in their 60s and there's you
know for my son you know let's say does
he need it um oh because it's meant to
prevent anyway I'm not saying not to get
it or get it I think that is the
personal decision I'm just saying like
how many people are really getting it
and then what does it say about
individual because it's different than
it's different than than even the covet
vaccine so-called vaccine I I don't
really call it a vaccine because it
didn't really seem to do what a vaccine
typically does with uh you know dead
viruses and so forth but anyway let's
call it a vaccine
um whereas this is saying something
about like the sexual like it's 100
preventable does he I mean you may not
like it if I say well you could prevent
AIDS by never having sex whatsoever
um getting any transfusions that's
pretty rare nowadays too like it's not
it's not politically correct to say that
but it is true it is theoretically 100
I'm not advocating people don't have sex
gay sex heterosexual sex whatever you
like okay but I'm just saying the fact
is scientifically you can't argue with
that but now we have to debate this
because of the ideological capture of
some of these institutions so if
Scientific American tells me
that we successfully deflected an
asteroid before it entered the Earth and
uh produced more meteorites that you're
uh that your audience can get at
briankating.com uh the uh the uh I will
trust that the problem is they're
they're like a weather forecaster who is
like 50 right 50 wrong and and
especially at Scientific American where
they've decided that their mission is to
wade into gender ideology
so yeah reporting facts and sort of our
opinions as facts um and I I don't
biased but this is a long-standing trend
and and here's where I witnessed it in
my first book losing the Nobel Prize was
the statement that you know 70 Nobel
Prize winners Advocate voting for
Hillary Clinton or for Joe Biden and and
every four years we get the same thing
it's always just look up X number of
Nobel Prize winners why you should vote
for the Democrat it doesn't matter who
the Democrat is it could be like someone
who's anti-science or or what have you
so they all vote so is that a capture
are the Nobel list themselves captured I
talked to one recently and I was like I
noticed you had like in your signature
you have your pronouns and I and I know
you very well this Nobel Laureate and I
was like did you do that like was that
important to you like because maybe I
should do it you know and he's like I I
didn't know like no I didn't agree to
this or that and and I was like well
this is strange like you know it's like
in your signature or or you know so I'm
wondering to what extent that we need to
rely on Experts comes down to the human
brains unwillingness to accept what I
call Schrodinger States ambiguous States
it's much easier to be 100 say F
Scientific American you know when you
talked about would you believe
Scientific American if they told you
that we had some way to deflect a meteor
I mean I know literally nothing about it
but if if if I had to had a dial that
said yes no maybe I would I would go to
yes but when it came to anything that
was morally fashionable specifically
race gender uh trans issues ETC Not only
would I say no but I would say it's
almost invariably the truth is the
opposite of that thing so I think it
depends in the subdomain about the
Articles and you know our mutual friend
Michael Sherman who's come up uh one of
my closest friends he used to be a
long-standing columnist for Scientific
American and until the until the
ideologically captured but I just don't
know Brian this is a larger issues but I
just don't know how we can function as a
society with all of these institutions
captured and large swaths of the country
not trusting them and that what's really
frightening about that to me is that
among the people who trust them they are
also in the orbit of the ideology so if
they actually knew and and Socrates
talks about this and
and the theatitis and a little bit in
the Republic but if they actually knew
what what either what went on in the
University or what the facts of the
matter is just as a simple thing and I
don't want to go down this rabbit hole
but can someone change their sex and not
go on this crazy redefining secretary
coins written about this Dawkins has
written about this I try to be
optimistic but I just don't know how we
can survive as a country when people
don't trust experts when people uh have
a when there's a wholesale legitimacy
crisis in our institutions and and I'm
I'm deeply concerned about the country
and it kind of connects back Peter to
the earlier statement that I believe
scientists have a moral obligation to
communicate their results in a language
the public can understand and if we
don't it redowns to our detriment
because eventually first funding will
dry up which is bad but eventually trust
will start to dry out because I don't
like if I don't talk to my brother you
know for like six months and then all of
a sudden you know I have this great
opportunity you know he's going to be
like well you know maybe my brother
wouldn't no no I love them but yeah but
some friend or something that's just a
fair weather friend and he comes up to
me only when he needs something
um you're not going to trust that person
and so I think the more we can have you
know scientifically educated or curious
you may not be able to do differential
equations like I can or you know my
guests can but to be curious about the
scientific process to be curious about
the new discoveries that is the cynical
non of human beings that we know based
on what our name is I mean you know the
name Homo Sapien means uh means a man
who knows so what is it that we know uh
it doesn't mean that man who is like
knowledgeable it means wisdom like
Sapienza means wisdom sientia science
means knowledge so you know talking
about science as if it's wisdom I think
that's very dangerous so when people
like fauci or other people were Collins
and so forth to suppress science to
obfuscate what they're doing and to
censor scientists like Jay about acharya
it's very dangerous and they should be
held to account that's the first thing
we don't have a Nuremberg Trial you know
but we we actually get them together and
say look this is where we do a
post-mortem and I see no interest in
doing that and covid was a lightning rod
and it was an opening of the eyes for
parents for scientists for uh lay people
all around the world about this
ideological capture that you speak so
eloquently about but again all this is
Downstream from Academia so the thing
that blows my mind like I don't it just
it blows my mind in a way that I can't
even
I can't even articulate how it blows my
mind it's this whole Quantum Computing
thing and I'm gonna I don't think I'm no
this does not betray a confidence when I
say this so I have a very good friend
who works in a high level at a
tech company and this individual has not
used their pronoun this individual told
me that tech companies have placed a
significant amount of money betting on
Quantum Computing to say the least a
non-trivial amount of money and and so I
I was wondering if one if you could just
give us a brief summary of that if you
if you feel comfortable doing that and
two can you relate the quantum Computing
to the possible existence of a
Multiverse not in the remaining 10
minutes or so but uh I can I can speak
about each one separately and I think I
think that's probably the most useful
way to do it there was a claim that they
there was a Quantum tunneling and and
behavior not unlike a wormhole uh and uh
Allied phenomena with the Multiverse
demonstrated in a quantum computer last
November by a friend of mine at Caltech
uh but we we won't conflate the two just
now so Quantum Computing is a
breakthrough in the Computing process it
was proposed by many people but most
particularly known uh popularized by
Richard Feynman as many things were in
physics who's been canceled you know in
some ways nowadays so we can talk about
that some other time uh and the The
Proposal was that there were certain uh
objects there were certain phenomena
that did not lend themselves to the
Boolean algebra the binary logic tree of
zeros and ones that are indicative of a
classical computer a semiconductor
computer the kind of which that we are
using right now at the trillions and
trillions level of the transistors on
each of our screens uh not to mention
all the supporting architecture so these
classical computers work by logic gates
that then can be converted to
mathematical operations that can process
at you know fractions of the speed of
light
um at uh to do computations much faster
than a classical you know computer could
do anything so these are zeros and ones
being processed at near light speed you
can think about it and you can break
down any operation all language as you
know for morse code is basically zeros
and ones all language all mathematical
operations can be use employing a binary
code to operate them
but uh if you had multiple if you had
trinary code or you know tertiary code
or or quaternary coat you could do more
operations simultaneously but it's still
discrete so you'd still have you know
four-fold algebra and so forth
um and Beyond but uh but now you could
get to a level we had like near
continuous a near infinite number of
bits per per you know Quantum transistor
which is called a qubit so these could
take on different values typically
encoded in either their spin of
electrons or um or topological effects
Solutions and polarons and and light
Optical quantum computers and they're
found to be incredibly descriptive and
useful these quantum computers at
describing the physics of quantum
computers
um right now a lot of what they do is um
doing things that need to be highly
parallelized so looking for prime
numbers is a very arduous task in
mathematics these objects can do that
and it's pertinent to everything we're
doing now because a lot of encryption is
predicated on finding prime factor pairs
that can be used to generate uh public
key encryption and then decoded in
private so that is a possibility to date
you know that's one of the major
opportunities of chronic computers as
well as understanding the properties of
quantum systems at very extreme
temperatures and pressures including
possibly these Newfound room temperature
superconductors if those are confirmed
and I'm sorry if this is such a dumb
newbie question I I'm not a physicist
but is there any relationship between
Quantum Computing and the Multiverse so
let me ask you the question this way
if at any
point in a trajectory of quantum
computing
let's say we're able to do utterly
extraordinary things would that be
evidence of a Multiverse no I mean they
used to say uh you know if you wanted
evidence for aliens uh you already had
it fermi's Paradox is answered because
there are people called hungarians and
as a Targaryen I'm I'm very proud of
that and I know you have affection for
hungarians as well I'm a big fan yeah
the um no there's not necessarily any
link between that now there are weird
aspects of the Multiverse that can be
envisioned as
um so-called splitting of the wave
function so in quantum mechanics
classical mechanics the position of an
object and velocity specify everything
that it can do and quantum mechanics you
need more variables but a similar type
of of operation conceptually now in fact
though when you do a Quantum measurement
unlike a classical measurement you
completely unavoidably alter the state
of that system permanently and
irreversibly collapsing the wave
function so right so-called double slit
experiment
um or the Schrodinger cat experiment
When You observe the cat it's either
alive or dead before that it's in this
hyper hyper superposition of living and
debt which is bizarre to Einstein and
others now in the Multiverse that is
called the many worlds hypothesis
popularized by our mutual friend Sean
Carroll uh and his wife she's not my
friend something deeply hidden
he might not like me very much anymore
either uh but anyway the um he did talk
about my research on this podcast by
this critic of Eric Weinstein but he was
very uh generous I should say so anyway
the um the Multiverse and that
instantiation takes the effect that the
cat lives in another Universe even
though in our universe it's dead so
that's a form of a Multiverse not not in
a distant cosmological Vantage Point
okay right so that's right that's the
thing just yeah okay so real quick we
only have a few few minutes left I would
love to get you on and talk about room
temperature superconductors I'd love to
get you on and really drill down on some
of the ideas we've talked about
metaphysics religion we didn't really
talk about the God hypothesis I'd love
to talk so I'd love to have you back on
but we have a question in the Super Chat
I want to ask you how do you view laws
against Holocaust and Island countries
like Germany Austria understandable in
their historic context you know
Christopher Hitchens was against that
and uh you know you have people like
David Irving uh deniers et cetera so you
have any any thoughts on that real quick
before we end this curveball question
for you yeah I mean I don't really feel
you know that this is something you know
that is pertinent on such a level as to
as you know as to really warrant uh
policy intervention from a physicist I
would say as a Jew
um these things are distasteful but I
actually don't believe in in you know
kind of suppression of hate speech I
think that that's kind of a tautology or
it's it's sort of a logical
impossibility that you could have free
speech and suppression of cases let's
say there's a baker you know who won't
make the bar mitzvah cake you know for
my son and because because I'm a Jew
well are there not any other bakers that
could do it and like should that place
be forced out of business by lack of
demand absolutely so should the
government come in and shutter it
um I think that leads to very dangerous
conclusions I don't know what happens to
not Germany Austria of course you know
they were complicit the people were
complicit they did suffer and I should
say that to my knowledge Germany and
Austria especially Germany has made his
heroic kind of yeah I agree attempts at
reparations I'm unlike the Japanese and
their treatment of Chinese Comfort women
Korean you know the the Holocaust that
they committed yeah
rape of I mean they have done less soul
searching I would say being ignoramus
about most of these political topics but
then the Germans which I which I have
great affection for and and I I don't
you know you know the of course
historically and it but if they they're
Germans right so they can do whatever
the hell they want it's like when people
criticize Israel that are Jewish and
they say well we should do this okay you
can move there I mean there's nothing
preventing you but like you're staying
here in America safe and sound for many
of the uh repercussions of your of your
I don't know what the repercussions are
in German I don't know how virulent
anti-Semitism still is I understand it's
still active it's active everywhere it's
like saying you know it's rising it's
it's rising it's ugly ahead again so I
just want to say as an Armenian someone
of a Armenian descent I mean I I I I
agreed with everything you said and I
was thinking about and I I want to be
respectful of your time so very very
very quickly before we wrap it up I was
thinking about well but what if you're
in Pakistan and you had like are there
ever circumstances when one would there
should be a law requiring such things
like as about the your son's uh Bar
Mitzvah cake and if anti-Semitism was so
malignant and so widespread and
ubiquitous would you need those laws in
other words that's for example why we
have a constitution to protect some
basic rights so states can make their
own whatever they want to do but they
can't they can't contradict the
Constitution right we can't so I I just
I was just thinking about a cultural
historical context okay so real quick
we're going to finish up but what do you
like what do you what do you do like are
you like I don't even know what are you
working on now are you working on like
like can you explain and maybe this is
unfair I don't even know how to phrase
the question like are you doing
experimental stuff or like what are you
working on now intellectually in in your
field
so in 1609 Galileo took the first uh
look at the heavens through a small
telescope and when he did that he he not
only discovered that Jupiter had moons
around it but he upended our concept of
the Paradigm of the geocentric Universe
in favor of a heliocentric universe and
substantiation via data and observations
of what's called now the copernican
principle which has been extended to
something called the cosmological
principle the fact is that telescopes
lead to data which lead to rejection
most people think that the job of a
physicist is to prove a theory or prove
that you can't prove uh that the
Universe had a big bang you cannot prove
it you can theorize about it you can
provide evidence for it but at any
moment new evidence could come in that
would supersede contradict it as has
happened many many times the structure
of Scientific Revolution but my job is
not to prove or disprove but it is to
provide evidence that then excludes the
models of theorists like Eric Weinstein
or Alan Guth or uh or if you like any
any other you know cosmologist who's
somebody who believes the universe
didn't have a big bang
um that's fine and we're not going to
suppress that that freedom right so my
job is to build with my students
post-docs colleagues right now the
biggest
cosmological project ever attempted of
this type is called the Simon's
Observatory it's located at 17 and a
half thousand feet in the Atacama Desert
in the Andes Mountains of Northern Chile
and this is not only the the highest
astronomical Observatory of its kind
currently
it's actually the highest construction
project on Earth it's 3 500 feet above
Everest Base camper they have like a
warming Shack or something so it's it's
an amazing logistical Triumph that my
colleagues on the Simon's Observatory
um people at Princeton Penn colleagues
here at UC San Diego at Berkeley in
Chicago all around the world 300
scientists ranging from undergraduates
to gray hairs and Beyond we are building
the most sensitive instrument which will
get first light to look back and look
for the telltale signs of a singular
inflationary origin of the universe
which Peter like what Galileo did
overthrew the biblical interpretation of
a stationary Central Earth this could
overthrow the notion of a singular
Universe in that it could provide the
first circumstantial evidence but
evidence nonetheless of a Multiverse
gosh and so to me it's the most exciting
thing that we call it's credible like
how crazy cool thank you so much for for
speaking with me I genuinely appreciate
it I appreciate you taking the time to
popularize science which is one of the
most important things that I I think we
can do is make these ideas accessible to
people and really explain in language
that even I can understand some some
pretty cool Concepts so I really
appreciate the work you're doing in the
in the public reality I said I have a
non-sexual crush on your mind and
everything you do okay awesome thank you
thanks a reed and Aaron and everybody
over there at uh bogosian Enterprises
that's uh